So a couple that I came up with are work ethic,
which can be kind of hard to categorize between learned and
innate. Cancer can sometimes be difficult to know if it's visible
or hidden, right, it depends on which level we're talking about
at the cellular or the total body level. Then you have
something like aggression, which can be hard to define as behavioral
or physical. That may be behavior you show, but the outcome
is physical, and so it might be how we quantify it.
Here's actually a word cloud of student responses
that you and your fellow classmates submitted. Remember that
in a word cloud, the bigger the word,
the more it was submitted by your fellow students
as a trait that's difficult to distinguish in
one of our three categories here. Look around the
list and see if you agree if some of
these traits are difficult to define in these categories.